Welcome to Think Fast Talk Smart,
The Podcast.
Think back to a day in your recent past,
did things go the way you expected?
Did everything and
everyone follow the script you planned?
Unfortunately, business and
life can be quite chaotic,
unpredictable, and even messy.
How can we better prepare ourselves
to manage all of this spontaneity
in a creative, collegial way?
Hi, I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Today I am really looking forward
to speaking with Christian Wheeler,
who is the GSB StrataCom professor of
management and professor of marketing.
Christian teaches a variety of courses
including those on behavioral research,
marketing management, and
spontaneous management.
Welcome Christian.
>> Hi Matt, great to be here.
>> I've really enjoyed working with
you on a few projects at the GSB.
You seem to have unending energy and
are amazing to watch teach.
I'm so excited about our conversation.
Should we get started?
>> Yeah let's do it.
>> All right,
as I mentioned in the beginning,
things don't always go as planned.
You teach a course in spontaneous
management, can you share with us two or
three of the key learnings
you impart to your students.
>> We all spend time making plans,
whether those are business plans such as
a quarterly earnings, forecast or personal
plans such that we rehearse in our
minds the way a conversation or
interaction is going to go.
And things rarely turn out
exactly like we anticipated and
that can be upsetting to people,
can throw them off of their game.
And so, the class spontaneous
management is built around this idea of
providing people a sense of calm and
flexibility so
that they can adapt to whatever
circumstances come about.
So, I know you talk a lot with your
students about managing anxiety.
>> Yes we do.
>> A lot of people feel [LAUGH] anxious,
even giving a plan scripted
presentation in front of others.
And how much worse is that when you're
dealing with circumstances that you
can't completely control
such as a question and
answer session that goes
differently than you anticipated.
Or just being asked to make
spontaneous remarks about something.
So one thing that we deal with right
at the beginning of the classes is just
learning to be comfortable
being uncomfortable.
All of us have some natural reaction
of arousal when we get in situations
like that, and that's not
necessarily a good or a bad thing.
What is good or bad is how we
respond to that sense of arousal.
And so, sometimes when we get into
situations where we need to make unplanned
comments, we can get a little anxious.
And then we get anxious
about being anxious.
>> Yeah.
>> We feel bad about being anxious and
that's where the problem starts.
There's nothing wrong
with being uncomfortable.
The problem is with your
discomfort at being uncomfortable.
And so we work on exercises teaching
people to be in that situation and
to respond in that situation
with a sense of calm.
They can acknowledge that they
feel a little bit anxious, but
they're not going to dwell on it.
And they're going to trust
their minds to bubble
up the necessary responses
that they have in that moment.
And it's when we start layering other
things on top of that feeling of arousal
or anxiety that it becomes problematic.
If you've ever watched American Football,
they talk about how the best quarterbacks
have to have a short term memory.
What that means is, if you go out and you
make a mistake, you throw an interception.
The next time you go out there,
you can't be thinking about that
interception you just threw.
You need to be thinking
about in the moment,
what you need to be doing to adapt to
that next series of plays that you have.
And so, the less time you can
spend dwelling on your mistakes,
the more mental energy you can devote to
doing what you need to do in that moment.
>> So I really liked that advice.
And a lot of this is just acknowledging
that getting nervous in those types
of situations is normal and natural,
rather than something that is bizarre and
strange.
Most people get that way and
then that can help short circuit some
of that anxiety you're talking about.
Do you work with your students on specific
things they can do to develop that short
term memory and to help reduce some of
that feeling bad about feeling nervous?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So I guess that was going to
bring me to the second thing.
We work on having a sense
of not fearing failure.
So failure is another thing,
you need a similar set of responses.
Failure is not something that we seek and
no one wants to fail, but
the fear of failure can create these,
layer all of these other maladaptive
responses on top of that.
And so what we do is we put
people into situations,
some exercises we do early on or
what improvisers called brain fries.
They're situations where your brain
simply can't compute all of the necessary
information.
And you learn to be in those
situations with a sense of comfort,
at least relative comfort.
And you learn to treat failure
as something that's okay.
Here in Silicon Valley we have this
mantra, many companies do of failing fast,
failing quickly and all of that.
And that's fine as
an intellectual orientation, but
many of us when we're confronted
with personal failure,
even with things that are not high stakes,
it feels bad to us.
And we work hard to try
to avoid that failure and
that can often be counterproductive.
So we try to encourage people to accept
failure as being something that's okay.
And to enter situations like that with
a sense of play and a sense of joy.
>> I once heard a wonderful get of advice.
That, just because you fail,
doesn't mean you're a failure.
Failing can actually be
a wonderful learning opportunity.
But it sound like a what you are trying to
inculcate in your students is this idea
that failing isn't bad.
And it's something you can
actually desensitize yourself to.
>> Failing is something that
is on the pathway to success.
People forget what it was
like to be a young child,
children are bad at everything.
[LAUGH] They don't know how to walk.
They don't know how to use a spoon.
They don't know how to tie their shoes,
they can't do anything.
And children fail and fail and
fail and fail and fail and
fail until they stop failing.
And so a young person is used to
failing all the time, it's no big deal.
And through failure,
they learn how to gain the skills that
they need to participate in life.
And as adults we get to some point where
we can structure our own environments in
such a way that we don't put
ourselves in failure situations and
that's where we stopped growing.
We need to recognize that failure is a
great thing because failure suggests that
we are operating at
the outside of our abilities.
And that we have some skills that we
can acquire it to better adapt to our
circumstances.
>> You remind me of a company I worked for
many years ago, we had failure Fridays.
And the CEO essentially rewarded
people for stepping forward and
acknowledging some work failure they had.
With the idea of being one,
what you're saying,
there is to push ourselves
to try new things.
And of course, when you try new things,
failure happens.
But also to be an educational experience.
So it was okay to fail, but
let's not make the same mistake again.
So those failure Fridays were actually
quite fun and people would compete to have
the biggest failure, and
it turned into quite an event.
But it was really something that helped
desensitize people to failure and
encourage learning.
>> Yeah, I love that idea.
I love that idea and
then everyone else can learn from
your failures as well, right?
They learn what didn't work and and
it destigmatizes your own failure,
that's great.
>> Absolutely.
So in your course you talk
about creative collaboration.
Can you provide us with some
practical tips on how we can be
more creative in our collaboration?
>> Sure, so,
one of the things we work on in my
courses is understanding your tendencies.
So all of us have We exist
along some continuum
of either wanting to seize control or
wanting to avoid control.
And so we do some exercises aimed at
helping you understand your basic
tendencies.
And then within that to recognize that
the things that your collaboration
partners are giving you are gifts.
So what a lot of people don't fully
appreciate about the creative
process is the value of inputs that
come outside of your own brain.
Whether they're from your environment,
or whether they're from someone else
that you're collaborating with.
But are there Kessler talks about this as
having intersecting reality planes, right?
We have two different ways of viewing the
world, each of us has our own perspective,
our own set of experiences,
our own set of associations.
And that when those things intersect
that's when you can have interesting
creative solutions.
And so when we're working alone we can
do things to foster that process, but
the collaborative process naturally
creates that type of thing.
And so one thing we work on
is viewing inputs as gifts or
as an improviser would say as an offer
as something to be built upon.
And so if you've read anything or heard
anything about him from improvisational
theatre that the first rule is yes and.
And so what we do is we affirm
what the person gave us and
then we build directly on that idea.
And what people who do these exercises
with me find is that they come up with
crazy innovative solutions.
That they never would have been able to
dream up on their own just by having that
additional person provided input into them
>> So do you teach your students or
do you have some recommendations for
some ground rules or
some direct that can help people
feel okay being creative?
And saying yes and there's a lot of
pressure to get things right and
I feel like that stifles this yes and
approach.
>> Yeah, absolutely, so
I think what's important and
the sessions I teach on creativity,
it's important to know which stage of the
creative solving process that you're in.
We often have a tendency to judge our
ideas at the same time we're creating them
and that's something that
humans are not good at doing.
There's a time to judge but that's not
the time when you're creating ideas,
you can judge ideas later.
>> So
you essentially encourage people to one,
recognize that we're in
the brainstorming and ideation phase.
Or we're in a different phase, and
in that ideation phase, anything goes.
Let's not judge, let's really focus on
how we can see what others are saying or
offers.
>> Yes and to build upon those things,
because we don't know the value of
an idea until we follow it
to its logical conclusion.
And even if we end up someplace
that isn't super valuable for us,
we may find that there are aspects of that
idea that are still valuable that we could
incorporate in a different way.
>> Certainly and I can only imagine
that in interacting with others in
that way collaborating in that way
it builds trust and camaraderie.
So that perhaps that idea wasn't good but
it might lead to the creation
of other good ideas.
>> Yeah, I think that's exactly right,
people are thinking a lot more about
issues of diversity, equity and Inclusion.
And I think that's really important to
think about in any given context you may
be an individual who
feels that you belong or
feels that your
contributions are valued or
feel like you have something useful to say
And the way people respond to your initial
ideas are probably going to affect the way
that you interact in that environment.
And what I mean by that is you mentioned
the valuation apprehension associated with
a group decision context, right?
I don't want to say something stupid or be
judged for that and I have some threshold
for how good I think an idea is before
I'm going to let it come out of my mouth.
And then I'm going to look to people's
responses to that and if that initial
response is negative the next time around
that threshold may be a little bit higher.
And so it's very easy to unintentionally
stifle the voices of people
who may have varying levels
of comfort with contributing,
because they feel that they
belong in that group or don't.
One thing that this orientation does is it
makes sure that you're hearing all voices
even those who may be a little more
reluctant to speak up initially.
>> And that is so critical for not only
good decision making and feeling part
of a group but just for furthering
this cause of diversity and inclusion.
Beyond focusing on spontaneity and
management you did some research on
what you referred to as
positive implying pronouns.
Can you give us the scoop on how our
language use specifically pronouns
might help us in our communication
>> Sure so the pronouns that we use
indicate something about the relationships
that we have with others or
the norms of this situation.
So that research was about the language
that businesses use to communicate
to customers.
So if I'm in a joint business venture
with somebody loosely speaking,
meaning that I'm a banker trying to
communicate to a potential client.
Or I'm an insurance company trying to
communicate to a potential client,
how do I talk about that relationship?
One way we could phrase that
as I could say, you and
I will work together to
meet your financial needs.
Or I could say we will work together
to meet those financial needs.
And what research shows is that
when people use pronouns like we,
that is indicating implicitly.
But in a way that people pick up
on it's indicating closeness and
a shared identity.
So if you look at committed
relationship partners they use
the word we more often than not.
We, our and us, this pronoun
that implies this togetherness
versus separateness pronouns such as I,
me or you.
And if you look at the spontaneous
language of couples,
couples who use these
inclusive pronouns like we,
have higher relationship
satisfaction than once we use I.
And so it can be an indicator of
the type of relationship that you have.
I mean it can also increase relationship
satisfaction when you tend to use those
pronouns.
But how successful that will be will
depend on the existing norms of
the situation.
So in a business context, what our
research showed is that there are certain
industries for which people have
expectations of a closer relationship.
And other industries where they feel they
have an expectation of a more distant
relationship.
And that people responded more positively
when the pronouns used reflected those
existing norms that people
had in their minds.
We also know that the use of the pronoun
you just referring to you as you can
increase what psychologists
calls self referencing.
Which means that you are relating
the information to yourself, so
if I say something like computer
technology is changing every day.
Or I could say Matt you know the computer
Just adding that you there makes you more
likely to think about that information
in a self relevant way.
Just along the lines of
using someone's name,
which relates to some other
research that I've done.
>> Interesting, so
using you using someone's name
invites people to pay attention.
And then do some self reflection in a way
that they might not if you don't use that
language.
>> That's right, yes we recently
published a paper showing that just
putting someone's name in the subject line
of an email even when they know
that you already knew their name.
Increases their likelihood of opening
the email and increases the likelihood of
generating sales lead or having them
click through to it to another page.
And interestingly it decreases
unsubscribes and the way it has this
effect is through increasing elaboration
of the information in the message.
So if you provide compelling
reason to adopt the product or
to browse on the webpage then they're more
likely to do that when you use their name
in the subject line.
Even again, when they know that you know
their names such as with Stanford alums,
or an existing customer of a company.
>> Fascinating, you talked about and
we talked about this notion of rapport and
bonding and feeling part of something.
It goes without saying that teams
that know each other well tend
to work better together.
Unfortunately, we don't always have
time to bond with our colleagues.
Or perhaps with our new
ubiquitous remote work,
we don't have the benefit of in-person for
lack of a better term schmoozing.
I've seen you help teams bond rapidly,
what advice and guidance can
you provide to help us get to know our
coworkers better and more quickly?
>> You raised a really good issue there.
This remote working thing is dramatically
changing the way that organizations
function, I think.
So one fear that people had,
if people are coming into the office and
I'm not there to look over their shoulder,
maybe I'm worried they're not
going to get any work done.
That turns out, from what I've seen,
not to be true.
People are certainly capable
of supervising themselves and
getting work done.
But what we do miss is this
contact that we have with people
stopping by their office or
running into them at the water cooler.
These little interactions with one another
have a huge effect on the level of
bonding that we feel with one another.
So we know that proximity for example
is one of the biggest predictors of
attraction, that just means how
close we are to individuals.
You're more likely to be friends with
someone who has an office or cubicle next
door to you than someone who has
an office or cubicle on the second floor.
And also, there's this principle
developed by Bob Zajonc, who was
a Stanford psychology professor before
he passed away called mere-exposure.
Simply coming into contact with something
repeatedly makes us like it more.
And so these little interactions,
that we may not feel that they're
a critical component of our
organizational functioning,
have a huge effect on how
close we feel to one another.
And when we have those frequent and
positive interactions,
they form the foundation for trust.
And the foundation of trust helps us
identify more with our organization and
the organizational mission.
And what we've seen here with meetings,
for example, is that we often think of
the purpose of meetings is just to be
the things that are on the agenda sheet.
But what we see is that meetings have
a lot of other functions, they serve
the socialization functions, even if it's
not an explicit part of the meeting.
We show up to the table a few minutes
early or linger a few minutes afterwards.
And we have this incidental contact with
others that is taken away when we're
working in this remote environment.
One thing that organizations need to think
about is ways to artificially induce
that into this more formal Zoom style
interaction that we've adopted.
So in my exercises what we do is we help
people engage in exercises where they're
interacting with one another,
they're experiencing this positive affect.
And they're engaging in some
degree of self-disclosure,
which is something that creates
the foundations of trust.
>> Can you give an example, one or
two examples of an activity that you do?
I've seen you do multiple ones,
I'm curious if one or
two bubbled to the top
that you'd like to share.
>> Yeah, they can be very,
very simple things such as
minor acts of self-disclosure.
I have people, for example, psychologists
have developed these series of
questions to create rapport
in the lab artificially.
So oftentimes, people may want to study
closer versus more distant relationships.
But when you just bring friends
versus strangers into the lab,
there are all kinds of confounds.
But what they've developed is a series
of questions with escalating levels of
self-disclosure that can create these
feelings of a close relationship
even with someone that you've
met just mere minutes ago.
And so one thing we do is we have bring
people through those questions and
they escalate in a way such that people
generally feel comfortable revealing
something about themselves.
So it's not too fast, but it's faster than
you probably would normally in an ordinary
conversation with someone.
>> So give me an example
of one of those questions.
>> Well,
you start out with things such as, Matt,
how long have you been at Stanford?
Why did you come here, this type of thing,
moving through a series of questions
in a series of stages to get to more.
The last level, we're talking about things
like an embarrassing experience that you
learned from, or something you really want
to accomplish in the next 20 years that's
close to your heart.
>> So it's a gradual escalation where
each person reveals a little bit so
they feel more connected as they go.
>> That's right and what we've seen
through research is that, we like people
who self-disclose to us and we like people
more when we self-disclose to them.
>> This notion of self-disclosure in a
virtual world, I've done this with some of
the students I teach and some of the folks
I coach, where we'll just say take
something in the room you're sitting
in and just show it to us virtually.
It's like show and
tell when we were kids, but
it's a way of disclosure because people
will explain why it's important.
It also has this wonderful side effect of
making people turn on their videos and
people are loathed to do that sometimes.
So it feeds into what you're discussing.
>> Yeah, that's an interesting thing that
we see with Zoom meetings now is that we
get glimpses into people's lives that
we wouldn't ordinarily have, right?
We see their living rooms and
their children and their pets and so
people are often engaging in unintentional
forms of self-disclosure that still give
us the feeling of knowing
that person better.
>> Absolutely,
I think you can connect to people much
more when you see more of them, for sure.
I'd like to move on and I know that you
use improv games to help your students
better understand the concepts you teach.
And I'm wondering if you'd be willing
to play a quick improv game that I
just made up.
>> All right, let's do it.
>> Okay,
I'm going to name a business activity and
I'd like for
you to respond with the first
thing that comes to your mind.
>> Sure.
>> All right, here we go, email.
>> Hell [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Tell me why,
what are your thoughts on email and
any advice on how to make it better?
>> Email is a bad form of communication.
I mean, some of it is our own fault, for
example, I'm not as good as I could be at
managing my inboxes and keeping personal
things separate from work things.
But even within a work inbox, there is
some things that are very important,
things that are unimportant.
And so one thing we can do as senders for
example is to clearly indicate in
the subject line whether this is something
that requires action on my part,
whether this is something that's just for
my information,
whether this is a newsletter or
that type of thing.
Because we end up in this endless task
without clear prioritization, there
are various technological solutions that
can help with that but nothing's perfect.
And then also, emails tend to be too long,
they're not prioritized efficiently and so
it's easy to start drowning in this swamp-
>> Absolutely.
>> Of email.
>> We, on this podcast, we've talked in
the past about how structure can really
help you when you're trying
to be efficient and concise.
And just thinking about how to structure
an email rather than just listing
bullet points can really help.
So I agree, being more concise and
direct is helpful.
Let me give you the last activity I'd like
your thoughts on, performance reviews
>> Approach.
>> Tell me more what you mean about that.
>> I think it's incredibly
useful to seek feedback and
I think most of us tend not to
do that as much as we should.
When we think about performance review,
when we're on the receiving end of that,
that's often a source of evaluation
apprehension or anxiety.
When we're on the giving end of that,
that can often be the source of
uncomfortable conversations.
But the only way you learn how you're
doing is through seeking performance
feedback.
And I think people should do it
more frequently than they do.
And again, if they have this orientation
that receiving negative feedback is
something on the pathway to growth, then
that can take some of the potential sting
out of hearing news that you
don't necessarily want to hear.
>> I like that,
that approach really does change.
And it feeds right back
into what you talked about,
seeing things as offers and gifts.
I mean, in some ways,
performance reviews are gifts,
they're tools to help you better yourself.
Just taking that mindset versus, I'm being
judged evaluated, I have to defend myself.
That could really change
how these things go.
>> Yeah, absolutely, and talking to all of
the communications lectures at Stanford,
that set is fantastic at doing.
They continually seek student feedback in
an open-ended way and they continually
revise their class so that they can
better meet the needs of the students.
I'm blushing Christian.
Thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Before we end,
I like to ask the same three questions
of everybody that I speak with and
I'm hoping you'll join me in this.
>> Sure.
>> If you would capture the best
communication advice, you ever received,
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would it be?
>> Five words,
I would say make a connection with others.
>> Okay, tell me more.
>> [LAUGH] Well, that sounds a little
trade on the surface of it, but
there are lots of things that
we do that can increase or
decrease our likelihood of doing that.
When I first came to Stanford we had
communication coaches that that help us
improve our teaching and I got some
fabulous advice that I never forgot.
One is I used to wander around
a lot when I was speaking.
I don't know if it was nervous energy or
I thought it was kicky.
It tends to be very distracting for
people.
They're moving their heads around
like they're watching a tennis match.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The communications instructor said to
me I want you to hold on to
this podium and don't let go.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I want you to just stand right here and
do not move and
when you do that when you can
deliberately use Stillness in your body.
>> Uh-huh.
>> It gives you incredible power as
a communicator,
when you can move with intention and
also not move with intention.
So you can create this gravity and
stillness when you want to and
then you can create a break.
Another thing that person said is to make
extended eye contact with people, that's
something I didn't bring up in the bonding
thing that we were talking about earlier.
>> Right.
>> But what this coach said, she says,
look, I want you to just pick one person
in the audience and look at them for
a few seconds.
And then I want you to look at
another person, pick them and
make eye contact with them for
a few seconds.
So she said, don't do the general sweep or
look into the far distance as though
you're watching a sunset in their eyes.
And then she said, I want you
to pick specific individuals and
make extended eye contact with them.
And what you find is that person is being
looked at they're paying attention to what
you're saying-
>> [LAUGH]
>> And interestingly the other people in
the room don't feel neglected by that.
As an audience member that's
a totally fine thing to watch.
But as the person being looked at it,
it makes that very strong connection.
>> And we're actually finding that
looking at the camera when doing virtual
communication has a similar effect.
So looking at the camera makes
the people on the other end feel like
you're talking directly to them.
>> Absolutely, and it's so
hard to do because you're trained
to make eye contact with people,
which virtually assures that you're
not looking directly into the camera.
>> Right, so
let me ask you a question number two,
who is a communicator that you admire and
why?
Well, I don't normally think about
communicators that I admire or not,
I guess I'm going to say I
give you a weird answer.
I'm going to say Elizabeth Strout.
>> Okay, I want more information.
>> She's a novelist, we often don't
think of when we think of communicators,
we often think of orators or
business leaders.
I think novelists are clearly
communicators and what I like about her,
she's a fabulous writer, but
good novelists revealed that they have
very keen powers of empathy and
observation.
So she writes about a person Olive
Kitteridge, who is a dislikable person,
but she's the protagonist
of many of her books.
And through placing you
in the mind of Olive,
you gain this level of empathy with her.
And so for
Elizabeth to be able to do that,
she needs to both understand what
a person like that is like and
then to be able to convey that to you
in a way that you empathize with it.
And so I think to be a good communicator
you need to have keen powers of
observation.
You need to be able to read
the people in the audience and
understand their reactions and
how they're responding to you.
And you also need to have that empathy to
take their point of view to understand
what they want to get
out of that interaction.
And when novelists can do that, in a way,
particularly by depicting dislikeable
people, as someone that you can still
identify with, I think is just incredible.
>> I'm smiling because I'm thinking a good
novelist has to be able to read his or
her audience so that the audience
in turn will read their stuff.
So a lot of reading that
has to happen there.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> Okay, the first one I'll double up on
a bit, I guess I'll say attentiveness.
You need to be attentive to the situation.
Another one I would say
would be vulnerability.
And the third one I would say is openness.
I mean this in a way that's an orientation
toward the world of curiosity and
lack of judgment.
That if I'm really going to be engaging
in a successful interaction with you,
I need to listen to the things that you're
saying with a sense of curiosity and
a lack of judgment so
that I can respond in a truly open way
>> Well Christian all of us have been
listening to you with an intense
curiosity and we have learned so much.
I thank you for sharing with us
your insights into communication.
To my mind, what I heard you say as it,
it all boils down to approach,
having an open approach,
seeking offers, being open to failure,
really being attentive and
responsive to the needs of
those you're communicating with
can make a huge difference.
Thank you for your time and
thank you for your insights.
>> Thanks, Pat.
[MUSIC]
>> Thanks for joining us for
another episode of Think fast Talk Smart,
the podcast.
Produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business.
For more information and episodes,
visit gsb.stanford.edu or
subscribe to our show wherever
you get your podcast.
Finally find us on social
media at Stanford,gsb.